welcome everybody uh my name is
professor jay bhattacharya i'm going to
talk today about
focus protection
and using covet 19 as an alternate
strategy to the lockdown and mandate
focus strategy that we have used thus
far
let me share some slides
so uh the the cover 19 vaccines are a
fantastic tool but only if used the
right way
thus far we have used these cova 19
vaccines in a way essentially aimed at
eradicating the virus or reducing the
spread of it but in fact that has been a
a an enormous mistake in order to build
that case up and describe an alternate
strategy of using these these fantastic
vaccines uh i'm gonna i'm gonna need to
go go back in time just a little bit
um
so
i am the co-author of a
document called the great barrington
declaration
the the document which i wrote and with
with two colleagues of mine uh in 20 uh
2020 in october 2020 calls for focus
protection i'll describe that in a bit
it's motivated by two basic ideas
one is that the harm from the virus from
being infected is is extremely age
specific
in the sense that uh people who are
older have a thousand fold higher risk
of severe outcomes from the disease than
um than than children do for instance
the second fact is that the the
collateral damage from the policies that
we have followed have been catastrophic
they've harmed people around the world
and have likely caused far more deaths
and damage especially to the less
vulnerable people
than the the lives they may have saved
uh and finally i'll talk about the the
uh the social inequalities caused by
these lockdowns with uh with it with an
emphasis on how the vaccines can be used
to avoid all of these harms
uh
so i wrote the great branch declaration
of two of colleagues of mine one of
martin kuldorf from harvard university
and then uh
dr sinatra gupta professor central gupta
from oxford university
it advocates a policy of focused
protection as i said there's a
thousand-fold difference in the risk of
death from the oldest to the youngest uh
it's it's an alternative to both a
leaded rip strategy or sometimes called
a herd immunity strategy where the virus
is allowed to spread as widely as
possible
and a and a strategy of of lockdowns
essentially the the the
focus has been to stop the virus from
spreading all together perhaps even
eradicate it um
by the way in a possible dream
uh we want to minimize both the harms
from covet deaths and the collateral
damage from lockdowns the current policy
we followed is focused mainly just on
covid deaths and not on the lockdown
damage at all
uh the the the great painting
declaration was signed by
thousand medical scientists fifty
thousand uh medical practitioners and
almost uh uh almost nine hundred
thousand members of the public from
around the world it's reason it's called
the great parenting declarations because
we signed it at a in great barrington
massachusetts where we met to discuss
covet policy
so let me talk a little bit about the
the risk from this virus in particular
the harms from
from getting infected and the mortality
from getting infected
in the early days the epidemic
the thought was that there was a uh a
three to four percent mortality risk
from if you were infected this was
something that the the world health
organization for instance said in the in
the very earliest days of the epidemic
they're basing it on a calculation where
the numerator was the number of
identified patients who had cobit who
died from it divided by the number of
patients who uh were identified with
cova and
potentially recovered from it so at that
point in april 2020 about three percent
of people who were identified with covid
die from it
now uh i ran a study called the santa
clara sierra prevalence study i was a
senior author of that study uh it was it
was uh conducted in april 2020
and the the the central idea behind that
study is that in fact for every person
identified with covid
especially in those early days when
there was limited testing resources
there were there were likely many other
people who were infected
that recovered from it
uh this disease is an incredibly
infectious disease uh one person getting
it can spread it to multiple other
people
the idea that we
we in april of 2020 had only uh you know
he had identified all the cases with the
limited testing resources we have just
didn't make sense especially since the
respiratory virus that spread so rapidly
in order to check this hypothesis
we uh me and my colleagues we conducted
a a study
of checking for antibodies in the in a
population in the in population at large
in santa clara county
now antibodies as you probably know know
is is are are formed after exposure to
the virus so uh if you've
been exposed to the virus and recover
from it
the lingering evidence of antibodies
is strong strong evidence that you have
previously been infected
if you just look for the virus itself
well after you they're better you've
cleared the virus you're going to
underestimate the total number of people
who've been infected in the denominator
of the the death rate calculation
in fact that's exactly what we found in
early april of 2020 2.8 percent of santa
clara county had a had evidence of the
virus
antibody happens to the virus
there's about two million people in
santa clara county
that implies there were about 54 000
infections
at the time in santa clara county only
about a thousand people had been
identified as having a virus
and there were about a hundred deaths
so if we just did the math we'd say the
case survival rate was ninety percent a
hundred over a thousand is ten percent
one you know what one minus that is
ninety percent cases right away ten
percent that's a pretty pretty deadly
virus
on the other hand if you understood that
that many many more people 54 times more
people had been infected than were
identified the infection survival rate
turns out to be 99.8
a much much higher
in fact infection survival rate
um okay so if you look at the the age
gradient it it becomes of the risk of
being infected it quickly becomes clear
that not everybody is at equal risk for
the virus
children
young people are at vastly lower risk
from this virus to date in the united
states for instance more than 80 percent
of the deaths have occurred in the 65
and up population
uh and from uh from very early days of
the epidemic this was evident my my
colleague martin kudor in april 2020
wrote an essay where he
we found that there was a thousand-fold
difference looking at data from china
between the risk of mortality for people
from this virus for people who are
younger versus people who are older
now this has now been confirmed by a
whole very large number of zero
prevalence estimates um so this is from
a study that was conducted in june of
2020 in stockholm
and the finding was this these numbers
are survival rates if you're infected
uh so for instance for for women
or girls who are
you know zero to nine years old the
survival rate if you're infected with no
if you have no underlying conditions is
extremely high
99.99996 percent
on the other hand if you're over 80 in
your you have no underlying conditions i
mean it's it's a it's a much more deadly
disease the survival rate's only 98.9
percent if you have one or more
underlying conditions and you're 80 or
years old and you're a woman uh the
survival it's even lower does it higher
i guess pardon me lower uh so if 92.8
percent if you have one or more
underlying conditions and you're a woman
for men it's even lower it's about older
men it's even lower so it's it uh for if
you're 80 and over with no underlying
conditions survival rate for infected
was 96.3
percent if you are if you have one or
more underlying conditions you're a man
in in
in the study with what they found was
this only a survival rate of 79.9
on the other hand if you're young men uh
young boys
the survival rate's exceedingly high
upwards from 99.99
okay so what's the right thing to do in
the context of this well the lockdowns
themselves have had an enormous harm uh
have caused enormous harm to the younger
populations we closed our schools we uh
robbed young people of
of of opportunities in life and i'll
show you some of the harms the public
health harms from these lockdowns
later
the right strategy given this aid
stratification of risk is to
take that fact and protect the people
who are most vulnerable
in this case with this virus this age
stratification is substantially higher
even than the flu
um the the right strategy is focused
protection of the vulnerable high-risk
population now of course there's still
some people with with chronic conditions
who face a higher an elevated risk as
well and focus protections extend to
them as well
that's plank one of the
great barrington declaration focused
protection of the older population
plank two is that young young adults may
live near normal lives
with the idea of minimizing collateral
damage for them the harms of the
lockdown far exceed the harms from covet
itself so for instance letting children
go to school and play with friends is is
essential to their health and well-being
whereas uh the the harm from stopping
that is much greater than the heart from
covet for children
well how should we protect the old
well now that we have the vaccines that
we have that have had the vaccines since
december of last year uh the priority is
if the idea is to protect the old by
vaccinating them first that is as good a
job of focus protections we can do for
the older population
and now
many countries have adopted that
strategy but they prioritized older
populations essentially adopted
something like the great the one of the
planks the great branch direction the
focus protection strategy once the
vaccines came available
we haven't done such a good job as a as
a world in doing that there's still many
poor countries where many older people
live that do not have access to the
vaccines and will not have access for
quite a while
so the idea of focus protection is to
prioritize the vaccinating the old both
within countries and between countries
um before the vaccines and actually
still to this day we there are other
strategies we might follow especially in
places where vaccination rates are low
so first uh and
primarily like is is this is just this
seems so obvious now that was less
obvious i guess in april 2020 do not
send infected pla patients back to
nursing homes uh that had has led and
had led to an enormous
number of avoidable deaths that occurred
in the early as the epidemic simply
because people did not understand
officials did not understand how steep
the gradient in age risk was
now second
you could you could frequently test
nursing home staffs and visitors unless
they're immune minimize staff rotations
in nursing homes let older people work
from home if it's impossible offer
temporary retirement sabbatical rather
but rather instead what we did was we
we
declared two classes of workers an
essential worker and a non-essential
worker and essential workers were
required to work
even if they were vulnerable
we could minimize multi-generational
living for instance by having temporary
housing and letting students actually
come to universities rather than closing
them down we could have uh free home
delivery of food for older people we
could encourage people to meet outdoors
and so on and so on the the only limits
to understanding how to protect the
vulnerable are the imagination public
health officials the primary problem has
been that older that
for much of the epidemic
the public health officials have relied
on lockdowns as a way to protect the
vulnerable and that has catastrophically
failed
how well can the strategy work well let
me give you a a
a couple examples uh uh two three
examples to give you what and then i'll
talk about the united states um one is
sweden
in the early days of the epidemic sweden
followed a strategy that was more akin
to the great parenting declaration
although there were great failures in
protecting uh nursing home residents in
stockholm where where in the early days
the epidemic the the just like in new
york the the co-infected patients were
let that let in causing enormous death
in the winter of this past year uh the
and the in the fall this past year there
was an enormous wave of cases in sweden
starting in october then peaking
sometime in in mid-december and huge
numbers of deaths that followed
um
the swedish
rollout of the vaccine actually was
relatively slow compared to compared to
say the united states
by march they'd only vaccinated about
seven percent of the population
but every single dose went to a elderly
person living in a nursing home or in a
in a uh or nearly every single dose
point or or one to uh uh older people
living in the community so that was
focus protection they didn't have 100
vaccination rates coverage but what they
did have was the use of the vaccine in a
way that recognized the harm that the
risk that older people faced
and then they had another massive spring
wave of cases you can see it in the
upper figures a huge increase in cases
that rivaled the increase in cases that
had occurred during the during the the
winter
whereas in the winter if you look at the
bottom graph there was an enormous level
a number of deaths
in this in the spring wave
the case rise was met with many many
fewer deaths there was not the there was
a missing hump in deaths
by using the vaccine for focus
protection
the swedes had effectively decoupled the
uh the the cases from the deaths focus
protection meant there was no spike in
deaths during the spring wave
that that is the fruit of focus
protection
well uh here's another example the uk
that's a very very similar story uh now
the uk had a much better role out of the
vaccine than sweden did
in this in the winter before the vaccine
there was an enormous
peak in cases in in the uk
and correspondingly enormous peak in
deaths from the virus in the uk
as the delta variant spread in june july
of this past year there was an again a
huge
outbreak of cases in the uk
but many many fewer deaths because in
the interim between between uh january
and june the uk had successfully
vaccinated a very large fraction of its
population especially
starting with older people first
what about in developing countries well
the strategies actually work to some
extent in a place like mexico which has
had a i say an indifferent vaccine roll
out still having trouble vaccinating
it's one of the probably in the world
average that so mexico has about
uh if the world averages about 35 doses
a 35 uh 77 doses for 100 people so 35
people fully vaccinated
equivalent um mexico's below that at 76
doses as of as a february 20 uh as as of
uh as of
late september of this year
uh mexico started his role out of
vaccines well in december of 2020 but
then in february 2021 they began the
task of vaccinating all senior people so
though they actually didn't prioritize
all little older population
nevertheless by july of this year they
had started they used many doses to
protect older people
what you can see is that again just like
nearly every country there was an
enormous peak in
cases in the winter
an enormous rise in deaths in in the
winter in mexico
with the spread of the delta variant
there was a huge increase in cases again
rivaling the winter wave
but
the number of deaths while not flat
uh was substantially lower than the
winter peak
the vaccine had blunted the harm from
the virus uh
it did partially decouple cases and now
if they'd done a better job with
vaccinating the old perhaps the would
have been quite much flatter father the
deaths would have been flatter just like
we saw in the uk and sweden
um
uh the u.s i'm going to just do a
slightly different comparison
this is these are data from the cdc i've
taken while i calculated covet mortality
per capita
for age group in the in through
september 2021 through the whole
epidemic and i'm going to compare two
different states one florida which
followed a much more free policy a
non-lockdown focus policy something much
more akin to the focus protection policy
we talked about versus california which
locked down very sharply my i live in
california for instance my kids
were effectively kept out of school for
almost a year and a half
the uh the fruits of this policy you can
see in this graph where i plot the the
age uh the the the mortality uh
rate from covid by age
for the 85 and up california had a
higher mortality rate for the 75 to 84.
california had a higher mortality rate
from 65 to 74. california had a higher
mortality i i don't want to
overemphasize the the the difference
here these are essentially equivalent um
same thing with 50 to 64 year olds 0 to
50 year olds florida has slightly higher
mortality rate you can see the the scale
is so small
um the key thing
is that lock down the while california
followed a lockdown policy it did know
better
it seems like lockdowns had literally no
no no difference in terms of the actual
outcomes on risk that that patients
faced uh as when you when you do the
stratification by a which you must given
the high age gradient in the in the in
risk
um wha what is going on here
so
one idea is the one one one key fact
about these vaccines is that the
vaccines as i said are quite effective
but they're effective in one way and
ineffective in another way the way they
are effective is by protecting people
against severe disease so this is a
study this is a graph from a study that
was conducted in qatar
where they tracked a very large number
of patients over time who had been
vaccinated
what you see is that at uh at after
about a month after
complete vaccination vaccine of efficacy
is very very high ninety five point four
percent uh efficacy
it wanes slightly but it remains
actually quite high uh
probably ninety ninety plus percent even
six weeks i say it's 20 to 24 weeks
after the second dose um more than six
months they didn't have a very large
sample size but uh it's still consistent
with
very effective vaccinations consistent
with very effective protection against
severe disease severe critical or fatal
stress co2 infection vaccines are great
for protecting people against severe
disease
they are less good at protecting against
infection this is the same paper
this now instead of looking at severe
disease looks at starscope to infection
what you can see is that in the first
month after vaccination you have 72
percent of efficacy of the vaccine
but that declines over time in this
qatari study the finding was that at 20
to 24 weeks
literally there was zero percent
protection
at six months against infection the
vaccine no longer protected against
infection it just protected against
severe disease uh you can see this in
the uk data for instance why did the uk
have this massive wave of cases in the
in the summer well
despite being about highly vaccinated
because it's consistent with the qatari
data that could what the suggest what
this implies is that the vaccine will
not and cannot be used to stop cases
from spreading this is not this vaccine
is not a tool for eradication or
establishing herd immunity or whatever
you like
this vaccine is instead a tool for focus
protection
all the implications for this for most
of the population covet poses only in
modest risk primarily the older
population is risco there are some
people with chronic diseases are also at
risk the vaccines provide durable
protection against severe disease
including death
but we have no technology to stop viral
spread
both lock down the vaccines that best
delay it
the corollary from this is that everyone
on the face of the earth
will contract covid probably multiple
times over the next
next few years
it's best if you are vaccinated when you
contracted the first time the evidence
is that after you've been vaccinated and
you can track covet you'll end up with
milder disease because you have severe
disease protection and even if you
weren't vaccinating you survive copa the
first time the second time it'll be much
milder there's evidence suggests that at
a full year after you've had covid
you're very strongly protected against a
re-infection and also severe disease and
death the second time you get it
although it sounds scary getting coveted
a second time or third time
will actually be much milder and
eventually the long-term outcome of this
disease is that it will become another
circulating coronavirus causing colds in
the population a population that's
largely uh
protected against it based either on the
vex or the vaccine or by prior infection
now let's talk a little bit about the
lockdown arms because this is something
that not gotten the attention it has
deserved
uh the public health consequence of the
lockdowns are enormous and will continue
into decades to come
among the harms include things like
missed cancer screens i'll show you some
evidence on that worst cardiovascular
disease outcomes if people skipped
getting heart disease treatment
because they were scared of coving they
skipped diabetic appointments plummeting
childhood vaccination rates worldwide
deteriorating mental health malnutrition
and starvation in countries around the
world and i'm just picked a subset i
could go on for a very long time
uh this is a study from early in the
epidemic looking at changes in the
number of newly diagnosed
cancer patients
uh and the blue lines on these graphs in
this graph are baseline this is before
the pandemic what you can see is that
just in the first month after the
lockdowns were implemented in the united
states there was a fifty percent drop in
breast cancer screening colorectal
cancer screening uh
not quite as sharp a drop in in in newly
identified lung cancer i'm sorry this is
not screening this is identified cancers
like there's actually similar results
for cancer screening as well
um
the point is
that these cancers didn't go away they
weren't the women in april of 2020
weren't uh were were not
uh you know the covey didn't cure cancer
so what happened is that women with
cancer stayed home
and as a breast cancer stayed home as a
result there will be many women who come
in today
with late stage brains breast cancer
that should have been picked up earlier
who will die from their breast cancer
but not from but
and
the way you should think about that is
the collateral damage from covet from
the covert lockdowns
um same is true for
hemoglobin a1c monitoring like an
enormous drop
in
screening in in tracking hemoglobin a1c
hemoglobin a1c is quite quite important
of course if you're diabetic and you're
and you're trying to
avoid some of the long-term consequences
of diabetes like macular degeneration
kidney failure and so on
um
vaccinations um well the the the the
copper vaccine is not the only important
vaccine there's an enormous number of
other childhood vaccines for instance
that uh that prevent
many many many times more deaths than
cobit itself than kovit
the vaccination programs worldwide
effectively halted through mut through
the because of the lockdowns through
much of 2020 while there was some uh
improvement later later in the year
the the the there's huge
decrease in vaccination numbers
worldwide for children so
there's at least 80 million children now
according to the un uh the world health
organization that at least risk of at
least one of the diseases like
diphtheria measles and polio for which
we have great vaccines uh polio actually
has been heartbreaking because we were
on the we were on the verge of
eradicating polio and it's made a
comeback in in pakistan or some other
places
but these are vaccines that are
extremely effective
in preventing child deaths and yet we uh
80 million
children
essentially skipped doses skipped
getting them in 2020 as a lockdown harm
the mental health effects of of cover
the lockdowns have been absolutely
devastating so just to give you one data
point this from june of 2020 this is a
cdc study
if you look at the 18 to 24 year old age
group
one in four of that age group in the
united states seriously considered
suicide in the past month one in four
the mental health harms from the
lockdowns are absolutely catastrophic
including
enormous numbers of cases of increases
in cases of depression increases in
cases of anxiety
and these are not things that go away
immediately when lockdowns are lifted
but in fact have a long tail
um
and then finally i'm going to just
mention briefly this that the the
lockdowns have had a devastating effect
on the poor around the world
uh uh the estimate suggests that at
least 100 million people have been
thrown into dire poverty that would uh
as a as a consequence of the economic
harm from the lockdown in poor countries
and this has resulted in
huge numbers of children
dying from hunger
around the world so this is an estimate
from um i think this was from the from
uh from the u.n suggesting that virus
linked tied to 10 000 child deaths each
month
um this is a study that was published in
science advances in january of this past
year
household i'll just read you a quote
from the conclusion house cell coping
strategies and government assistance
were insufficient sustained pre-crisis
living standards resulting in widespread
food and security and dire economic
conditions even three months into the
crisis
um covert 19 destruct disruptions killed
228 000 children in south asia says the
u.n report in march of this past year
mainly from hunger and poverty
let me finish by talking about social
inequality uh we adopted a strategy in
effect that only rich people these
lockdowns that only richer people people
who could afford to stay at home and not
lose their jobs
could do and we shamed poor people who
as we call them essential
effectively had to take over the risk of
going getting coveted in order to in
order just to survive right so what part
of social assistance in the united
people understand that is uh that is the
effectively the nature of the lockdowns
extremely unequal
we protected the young members of the
laptop class
at the expense of the poor and the
working class worldwide
now let me give you a bit of evidence on
this this is evidence from boston
um what you can see here is that
as as you get to places that are uh less
and less college educated from left to
right uh you you go you what you
actually what you see is a higher and
higher covet incidence in boston covert
was a was not an equal opportunity
disease it affected
neighborhoods with higher levels of
of of uh of
of uh
you know sort of
higher levels of poverty and
lack of
education um
but it's not actually covid
that was unequal what was unequal was
the lockdowns itself here's another
example from toronto the gray bar from
the early in the epidemic shows the 30
lowest income neighborhoods
during lockdowns
uh whereas uh the thirty highest income
neighbors the blue line you see very few
cases the lockdowns exposed people
living in the low income neighborhoods
while protecting people living in the
high income neighborhoods toronto's not
toronto and boston are not not outliers
in this uh and on the left part of this
graph i show data from los angeles
county from march of this year uh like
this actually similar to what you can
you could go look this up now it's very
same same exact result
what you see is that in areas that are
low poverty less than 10 percent only
118 uh deaths per 100 000 from covered
19 in l.a county but if in if you lived
in a high poverty area in ollie county
then the death rates were more than
three times higher 393
and
there were enormous race differences as
well
on the other hand by in florida there
was a
much more equal distribution of
of deaths per capita by race because the
lockdowns didn't happen there uh as i
showed you the the la there's very
little difference in overall death rates
per capita once you do the age
adjustment in florida
versus california and yet much more
unequal outcomes
here is a more systematic way of looking
at this in california latinos who make
up 39 percent of the population have
made up 55 of coveted deaths
in new york blacks who make up 14 of the
population are 23 of covert deaths
whites who make up 56 or 40 percent by
contrast in florida much more equal
latinos 26 percent only 24 percent of
kova deaths whites 54 percent 56 percent
of covert deaths
uh the lockdowns are
likely the most
unequal
health policy we have ever
ever adopted in at least in the past uh
at least in the past half
century so human rights are and freedoms
are most important for workers in the
poor the elites will always do what they
want and prosper uh the the the
lockdowns violated the human rights of
enormous numbers of poor people
worldwide did not protect them in fact
expose them for coding
so let me just let me just end there i
think that that we have with these
vaccines the opportunity for a much
better strategy much a strategy that is
better at uh at
protecting the vulnerable
not causing lockdown errands i think we
should we should adopt this these kinds
of strategies
that have an eye toward both equity and
and as well as uh
as efficacy
but with these vaccines we have the
opportunity to protect the vulnerable
lift the lockdowns and the mandates we
don't have a technology to stop cover
from spreading or to get to zero covet
that's that's an illusion and an
illusion that's causes enormous damage
we do have as a strategy to stop the
disease from
killing the most vulnerable thank you